[Música]
i
bien como ya habrán escuchado soy
jugadora e instructora de niños pequeños
de ajedrez
el ajedrez a mí me cambió mi vida es un
deporte juego poco conocido o poco
valorado pero sin embargo cambia mundos
cambia ideas nos abre la mente el
vocabulario nos ayuda a interactuar con
personas totalmente increíbles
a conocer lugares diferentes a vivir
nuevas experiencias
bien por lo que quería empezar era que
si se instructora de muchos niños cada
niño es una galaxia aparte así que es un
trato diferente con cada uno
ellos son criaturitas así super tiernas
van de los 6 a los 12 13 años pisando me
la edad
y quería decirles las tres cosas básicas
fundamentales que siempre les tengo
presente al momento enseñarles
como pueden ver allí eso es el famoso
tablero de ajedrez lo que me trae
locamente enamorada
ven un montón de dibujitos al que
nosotros llamamos piezas
cada pieza tiene un valor inicial o
relativo
por ejemplo los que están acá en
esquinita se llaman torres van en 5 los
siguientes son los caballos y los
alfiles que valen 3 la siguiente la dama
que vale 9 y el rey que es la pieza más
importante de todo el tablero
el rebaño infinito toda la partida todo
el juego
los cuatro casillas los cuatro cuadritos
que ven allí se llaman centros como el
mismo nombre lo dice están bien ubicados
en el centro de tablero así como
nosotros acá en nuestro punto rojo casi
en el centro del escenario
bien lo siguiente
es que voy a dar una charla de cómo
jugar bien al ajedrez desde mi punto de
vista
el xerez me ayudó a comparar partes de
mi vida etapas sueños cambios o algún
momento en específico
si se preguntan por qué le estoy
explicando todo esto es para que
entiendan a lo que quiere llegar
las tres cosas que siempre enseñan
primero es que están en todas las piezas
y juegan bien particularmente yo comparo
las piezas con mis compañeros con mis
amigos
con mi familia con conocidos o personas
que nos vamos encontrando en el camino
que nos apoyan nos brindan su cariño su
atención y nos hacen mejores personas
lo siguiente es que siempre cuidan o
pelean por el centro a lo que yo me
refiero es pararse siempre con un
objetivo en claro
siempre tener buenos argumentos no
tenerle miedo importa que o que se me
presenta delante yo sé que voy a ir
porque si ya vine ya estoy acá vamos a
darlo todo
la última
consigna por así decirlo que le da a mis
chicos es la protección del rey si se
acuerdan dije que era la pieza más
importante de todo el tablero
personalmente represento el rey con los
ideales con los sueños
con verdadero yo por lo que verdad
siento por lo que verdad lucho mi
objetivo que tal vez no lo tenga muy en
claro pero sé que quiero eso sé que
quiero algo
todo esto empezó a raíz de mi primer
torneo con una profesora me dijo tenés
que hacer una actividad que te expande
la mente tenía 8 añitos
como se darán cuenta
la primera vez que iba a competir
me denominaron el punto rosa
además ahora sigue siendo punto rosa
tengo medias rosas son bonitas era la
única niña la única mujer por así
decirlo de 8 años que tenía que
enfrentar a varones solo varones de
todas las edades muchísimo más grande
que yo con más experiencia más seguridad
y yo bueno una dieta así chiquitita
puntito rosa con chocolates en la mano y
todos los miedos encima no se imaginan
la cantidad de palabras negativas miedos
el terror de tener que dar un paso que
se me cruzaron la cabeza ese día y dije
no si algo me enseñó el juego fue que si
quiero algo lo tengo que conseguir así
que si ya estoy acá me voy a sentar en
mi caso voy a sentar trenton tablero y
voy a dar todo mismo no importa quien
sea la persona de ese me siento en
frente que baron en este caso
yo confío en mí misma confío en quien
soy en que las personas me apoyan
sé cuál es mi objetivo dar lo mejor de
mí en cada situación perder el miedo
ante todo
vamos a jugar si estamos acá
desde ahí empezó toda mi vida
actualmente siguen habiendo desafíos
siguen habiendo cosas que me tiran para
atrás como personas también que me
impulsan
intento siempre se refiere a mí misma
siempre a lo que quiero y mi charla
corta y mi mensaje un poco extenso así
que vamos a empezar por eso si se
recuerdan
eran tres objetivos son tres mensajes lo
que quiero dar el primero asociando con
el rey
sean fieles a ustedes mismos siempre
confíen en lo que ustedes quieren en lo
que anhelan en su meta a dónde quieren
llegar no importa quién lo que se me
presente delante yo no tengo que cambiar
quién soy yo tengo que demostrar que soy
ivette vaya en donde vaya me paré frente
a quien me pare a cuantos también en
este caso
lo del centro
vamos a otro objetivo parece seguro de
sí mismos recuerden por lo que vinieron
y para qué vinieron cuál es su motivo
parece bien firme en el centro así
nosotros en el centro del punto rojo
ustedes cada uno en un caso particular
póngase firme no importa cuánto miedo
tengan recuerden que siempre va a haber
alguien escuchando a alguien que le va a
cambiar la idea
ustedes son los que son por lo que
sienten y por lo que demuestran no hay
segunda oportunidad para primeras
impresiones
lo último y creo que
no por desvalorizando tampoco para
hacerlo más importante era el desarrollo
de todas las piezas
como ya dije las piezas son los amigos
son la familia son las personas
conocidas las personas que van
encontrando en el camino que nos ayudan
los guían estas personas son
y serán importantes hoy en la siempre
porque tal vez no tengan el mismo
objetivo que nosotros no todos van a
pedir a pararse acá y hablar pero si te
impulsan para vos sentís que te caes
bien en los amigos y tienen edades no
hay problema intentarlo cuántas veces
vos quieras no pierdan la fe
sean ustedes mismos cuiden de las
personas que más quieren durante todo
momento y siempre vayan con un objetivo
en claro
[Aplausos]
[Música]